scale bounce oh yes yeah where you have
a little dragons we saw we saw the
reveal where it's like here's something
from kamiya because they're working on a
game for every system and here's one
with dragons Platinum Games is busy
these days boy it was not just dragons
that we saw in the reveal to it was like
giant bug monsters some other colleague
it was sort of casting net a little
wider here in the gameplay demo of
course okay with the guy with the beat
yeah alright yeah let's talk about this
dude real quick his name is Drew and
he's from Earth he's Dante just like
Dante from double maker yeah well my mom
what's wrong with that Dante flow is
awesome he has a sword goes around cool
jacket some people are like over-the-top
one-liners that don't they have like
he's totally like a burro you know
there's a chicken kicking butt yeah but
I don't need Dante to point o with beats
though his attitude was definitely
something like circa 2003 video gaming I
don't know about that like it but he
does I mean would what we'll talk about
the combat abilities all right cuz
because I think that we all have sort of
a little off-putting reactions to this
sort of cool yeah I attitude but dragon
know in terms of this interrupt
interplay between the dragon and you
fighting at the same time what do you
guys think well I think I mentioned this
movie we're watching it that it it kind
of feels like it's the last guardian but
not for [ __ ] this is the last party
but your your dinosaur camping is gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he's not Duffy you breathe
fire and I tell them to go destroy
something and he does treat your dragon
for adults basically yeah like he flies
up he's just like shooting raining fire
down like I'm really curious how much
you have control over that and how much
it's just like here's an AI constructed
it it's deciding how it's gonna fight
stuff around you but if you have any
kind of control over if you're like they
go over there breathe breathe raining
fiery destruction on everybody like ah
that's that's pretty cool that's
actually really cool I love that I love
those scenes when you know he's just
fighting with the dragon and then this
scene that you're saying now where
another massive monster comes in and the
dragon and the monster just go
head-to-head you're like climbing up on
top of a monster and stuff it does these
are off and then you absorb it
apparently he's up that's what he's
doing right now right Joe things you
take their phone turn it into a bunch of
a little
Jim roll down its drama it's like it's
like Skyrim that's orbiting Dragon Soul
also has a huge monster hunter fan like
this is awesome like you're you're a guy
who's taking down big monsters you have
a big monster on your side like this is
the kind of game play that I love I
think Monster Hunters an apt comparison
because earlier in that fight we just
saw the conclusion of it there but there
is there was sort of you know having the
dragon work on some armor and then you
attacking but then you like the dragon
getting knocked on its ass and then you
sort of using that like dragon arm power
or whatever they call it to turn into a
more hulking warrior and then there was
like a grapple attack they did at one
point so it seems like these monster
encounters whereas fighting the human
soldiers will just kind of slashing them
up and smashing things which is great
especially for the power fantasy of hey
I get to go with dragon uh the monster
fights are the ones where they're gonna
be more tactically interesting and then
a mix of different weapons like you also
had the bow and arrow like you're kind
of you're a ranged attack and being able
to switch those up which built very much
more like a devil may cry game that you
have a range of weapons you're able to
access unlike a monster hunter where you
have like here's one weapon you're going
to learn how to use it really well so
like that's the thing that I like that
you have that mix of really fast action
oriented devil may cry we'd still like
some kind of strategic element and how
are you gonna take these guys down like
oh I need to throw a mine over and
that's gonna stagger this part of the
the enemy after I shoot with bow and
arrow and I can do some other attack on
that like that strategy mix like that
seems like it's gonna be really
interesting all right before we move on
I have two questions about drew my boy
so he's your boy no prob why I mean
intro voice is cool I he so this is
probably prefer the purposes of the demo
but he puts on headphones right and we
all made jokes about that but like do
you think I mean they're prominently
folk featured in his character design
and we are in the day and age where like
he could pull out a friggin ipod and
like like have an in-game playlist do
you think they'll be that kind of
musical integration uh I don't know
maybe we've seen what Final Fantasy 15
has coleman camping gear i think it
would be possible that we see a branded
headset music whatever may be like I
don't know Apple music he's got his
Apple music going wait and Sony you know
is a lot into hardware a lot
to their own headphones and peripherals
maybe this is going to be Microsoft's
entry into that is going to be your
limited edition scalebound Microsoft
headphones try get with your xbox one
dragon beats or the game became hum
knows if you listen to music through the
xbox and the guys hooked on the
headphones that started jamming out why
you've got your little super cool
surface pro choosing your playlist and
then he puts that on and you're
listening to Taylor Swift and ripping up
some mantises the other question is a
little more serious about gameplay is
like this is drew in his dragon but in
the reveal we saw a bunch of other
heroes and a bunch of other creatures
and we learned today that it's gonna
have four player co-op mm-hmm let's
let's get some speculation going here
you're probably gonna play as other
characters right I mean I would assume
so unless it's gonna be like a watchdog
situation where you're all the same guy
I'll be terrible just in the same area
can be terrible alright which other
monsters would you want to play as you
want to you want like a Mothra any of
you guys mafra face is what you want to
be the dragon why would you want
anything Yeah right this one has like
nine head I wanna be my Hydra oughta be
in a nine-headed dragon well you have to
fight against him I only give a [ __ ]
about this drag Hydra so like that
dragon did it look a little different
like these are all these are like your
dragons are looking different though
like they have a different look today
well dragons that can't fly or Drake's
so maybe there's some Drake's yeah
excellent or if you have anybody
customize those fighters if there's any
customization options that you have not
only for your character but for the
Beast that you have along with you like
yes and recycle you can get different
job bones and probably maybe put text
more arms onto your dragon I don't know
Davina like like your headphones they
light up in different colors your beast
is gonna also light up with different
colors along his lines of power driver
dazzle your own Beast in scalebound
that's slated for holiday 2016 when
another one of the big one which come
out against on 27 27 right did you guys
get the feeling from a lot of the 2016
release dates that it was really gonna
be 20 17 she was gonna get the laser
stuff but you doing the holiday 2016
always means like and you know we're
just pushing it a little bit out like
it's actually January still the holiday
of 2016 kind of in a way round about
that the winter 2016 it's like what
technically it's still winter til March
sure so
cool I didn't think about it they have
Microsoft has halo coming out this fall
therefore is it coming out this fall
they have rise of the Tomb Raider coming
out this fall I would imagine they need
something in their fall 2016 holiday
slate since all of their first party
stuff is sort of getting blown out now
chairs for can get here's for us next
year yeah people keep